leute wir haben hier wohnen only skin
care airport case einmal diese gekehrt
tragetasche wirklich in mini hey leute
was geht ab und damit herzlich
willkommen
tschuldigung falsche anfang ich komme
schon durcheinander alter weil ich so
viel schon für meinen neuen kanal
gedreht habe auch erster linie
beschreibung auf jeden fall abonnieren
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut mir auch wir
haben uns heute hier versammelt und erst
mal ein jahr kälter mir ist warm
entschuldigung moment wir haben es
gleich ja wir haben uns heute hier
versammelt um ein neues unboxing video
zu drehen und zwar ein video was sehr
gefragt ist ich habe oft der nachricht
bekommen alex wann kommt denn endlich
der zweite part dazu es geht nämlich um
die verrücktesten airports cases aus
aller welt bzw diesmal die verrücktesten
airports cases von misch viele von euch
haben wahrscheinlich das video gesehen
wo ich dort ordentlich eingekauft habe
für 400 euro und ja nicht ganz die
hälfte der airports cases ich komme mal
durcheinander eigentlich heißt es das
heißt ja wirklich airports cases ist ein
zungenbrecher und nicht airport cases
nicht ganz die hälfte ist auf jeden fall
schon da es reicht aber für ein video
und ich bin gespannt was hier drin ist
wir schauen uns die erstmal noch mal
kurz hier an und dann werden die
ausgepackt und dann bin ich mal gespannt
welche mir am besten gefällt letztes mal
hatten wir das amg case mein absoluter
favorit habe ich es ab gefeiert mal
gucken ob wir mit diesem part das noch
toppen können ich bin gespannt wir haben
als erstes hier ein case was silikon
potts ihr von case was leuchtet glauben
okay und ich habe das in pink bestellt
das müsste angekommen sein bin ich mal
gespannt ob das wirklich funktioniert
dafür müssen wir dann logischerweise das
licht ausmachen
dann haben wir als nächstes ein
spongebob case da habe ich auch mehrere
von bestellt hat mich fünf euro 85
gekostet 3d kyu spongebob silicon case
ich denke ihnen lieber wenn ich das
vorlese an brüste
wegen silikon aber es ist ja also
theorie rein theoretisch könnte man so
ein airport case einer mittel und dann
gebe ich dass dr
besser nicht aber theoretisch wird er
gehen oder ok egal
gehen wir nicht weiter darauf ein und
dann haben wir hier ein ikea case das
ist jetzt zwar nicht beschrieben als
ikea case aber ich glaube das kann man
hier ganz klar entnehmen
für sechs euro ich meine dass auch
angekommen da bin ich auch sehr gespannt
darauf ob das sind echt wirklich geil
aussieht und ob man damit rum laufen
kann oder nicht dann haben wir hier noch
war ich war auf jeden fall früher xbox
fan ich hatte eine xbox keine
playstation heutzutage habe ich eine
playstation und hier haben wir einen
xbox controller der ist auf jeden fall
angekommen das ist so ein richtig fettes
ding das ist bis jetzt vielleicht sogar
mein favorit und was auch noch da ist
müsste diese patrick pace sein
dann habe ich noch ein zusätzliches
paket da weiß ich nicht ganz genau
welche das ist auf jeden fall haben wir
einige holen heute und die werden jetzt
erstmal schön nacheinander ausgepackt im
letzten video habe ich die verrücktesten
iphone 11 oder generell iphone cases
vorgestellt das könnt ihr euch auch auf
jeden fall mal anschauen da waren viele
coole dabei das hier war mein favorit
den behalte ich auch diesen nackten
simpson
ich bin ein bisschen durch ich weiß okay
let's go ach so leute was mir gerade
noch eingefallen ist ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob ich nur für die airports der
erst und zweiten generation pillen
bestellt habe oder cases oder auf der
erbse das merken muss ich mal noch main
airports profi kraus kam kaum ein
anderes auch schon okay dann wollen wir
mal anfangen mit dem unboxing und zwar
mit diesem case also ist das
langweiligste okay also hier ist
wirklich ein spongebob drauf ist auch
für meine airports geeignet nächste okay
das ist irgendwie ein bisschen leben
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen körper da
kommen noch coolere sachen wir schauen
wir ob das passt zack und also sieht das
aussieht auch irgendwie ein bisschen so
aus als wäre das aber ich glaub ich hab
dich hab ich die falschen drauf die habe
ich nicht da fehlt so ein bisschen der
grip vom case das rutscht übels leicht
hier wieder ab vom vom case und so soll
es ja eigentlich nicht sein
also das ist wirklich auch vom muster
sehr sehr billig aber feiere ich jetzt
nicht wirklich würde ich nicht empfehlen
das zu kaufen ich verlege euch gerne
alle cases die ich gekauft habe in der
video beschreibung machen wir einfach
mal weiter
vielleicht mit diesen dingen hier ja
okay jetzt wird's auf jeden fall schon
interessanter das ist der 3d spongebob
aus silikon so wir haben hier einmal den
deckel dann haben wir den spongebob fürs
case und noch so einen anhänger dingen
ist ja auch noch bei dann mache ich das
jetzt mal drum
vielleicht sind sie kaputt ich sehe es
schon kommen also da
da muss man wirklich vorsichtig sein
dass man die nicht kaputt macht wenn man
das case wieder lösen will
das kann nämlich glaube ich schnell
passieren haben wir das auch mal
geschafft dann ab geht's okay
und das kann ich denn jetzt noch jetzt
stellt sich mir hier nur gerade die
frage wie ich das hier drüben krieg
machen wir es mal
wir hängen das war einfach so ein
bisschen provisorisch wir dran ich habe
natürlich auch wie immer vor da ich die
cases meistens nicht selber behalte die
kommt dann meine ins tor story und da
werden ja noch verlost weil sie keinen
bock habt ihr einfach selber zu
bestellen für sind ja jetzt nicht so
teuer einfach auf die story antworten
also dies auf jeden fall besser als
diese hier aber so richtig krank
abfeiern tu ich dir jetzt auch nicht
muss ich leider sagen na ja zum glück
haben wir noch ein paar ich bin ultra
gespannt auf diese pinke die im dunkeln
leuchtet das ist dann schon was cooles
für dich falls dir dort funktioniert
warum ist das dabei ich kann mich daran
erinnern dass ich mal ein pikachu
airport case bestellt habe es kann sein
dass das nein das kann eigentlich nicht
sein das ist auf jeden fall von roche
habe ich das mal bestellt vielleicht
habe ich das mit bestellt ich weiß nicht
so beim und jetzt habt ihr hier
spongebob und pikachu zusammen ist
unnötig ich weiß wo ich frage mich wo
dieses ding herkommt naja gut machen wir
weiter
leute wir haben hier sehr wohl
ikea hatte man kehrt case einmal diese
ikea tragetasche wirklich in mini so wie
man sie kennt also das feiere ich schon
dass die die halt wirklich so
nachproduzieren im kleinen man kann sie
sogar aufmachen moment mal geht es nach
klemmt ein bisschen ich glaube auch doch
es geht und tatsächlich dann als
portemonnaie nutzen und dazu hat man
hier noch einfachen standard airports
case in geld so jetzt schaue ich erst
mal dass ich die er passt hier wieder
raus bekommen kann man hier geht es ganz
einfach einfach den spongebob abziehen
und dann stecken wir hier ins gelbe case
der junge machen das zu jetzt schon mal
so aus und hinzu kommt dann die ikea
tasche ja moment so dann kann man das
auch wieder zu machen und ich würde
sagen
an sich ist das lustiges feature ich
weiß nicht ob man es unbedingt braucht
es ist halt mal was anderes also wie
gesagt das hier kann man sie als
portemonnaie benutzen und hat dann auch
noch ein bisschen seine airports
geschützt praktisch am portemonnaie dran
immer dabei also die dinger verlieren
kann man da nicht mehr so leicht das ist
bis jetzt auf jeden fall mein favorit
für sieben euro kann man da nicht
meckern also finde ich okay okay leute
das war's aber zum glück noch nicht wir
haben noch ein paar machen wir mal hier
mit weiter jetzt kommt das leuchten nein
moment mal kurz jetzt habe ich mich da
vertan die ist aus welchen gründen auch
immer auch noch bei mir gelandet und
zwar haben wir hier eine nasa hülle aus
hartplastik also dies wirklich die es
nicht aus gummi sowie diese spongebob
bringen
die ist aus extrem hartem plastik oder
hartgummi ich weiß es nicht genau also
auf jeden fall ganz andere konsistenz
feiere ich auch nicht so ab weil da
einfach nur stumpfe dieses nasa logo
drauf ist aber ich wollte euch das jetzt
trotzdem mal zeigen
hier muss ich jetzt natürlich auch
aufpassen dass ich die dinger gleich
wieder raus kriegt deswegen machen wir
das ganz vorsichtig zwar cruiser ist
jetzt mich so ganz rein gedrückt ich
weiß nicht bist ja langweilig erfüllt
ihren zweck auf jeden fall aber das war
es dann auch schon okay deswegen nehmen
wir da auch gar nicht weiter auf ein
jetzt kommen wir zu meinem eigentlichen
favorit das ist wirklich ein riesenklotz
der das ganze natürlich ein bisschen
sperrig macht zum transportieren
leute gebt euch das mal das ist meine
hand und dieses dingen ist ungefähr halb
so groß und es ist auch wirklich
verdammt schwer
das kommt auch noch hinzu das habe ich
total vermisst das war im ersten part in
jedem case oder ein leben in jeder hülle
hat dieses styropor dinge drin
as a ha und das ist jetzt anscheinend
wirklich für die probleme gedacht ja
cookie haben wir sagt rein und dann
kommt noch der deckel drauf und dann
kann man gegebenenfalls noch diese
klammer hier darum stecken und kann sich
das dann aufs readymade mäßig einfach an
die hose klemmen nein macht das besser
nicht bitte macht es nicht stellt euch
das meinetwegen an einem schlüsselbund
oder so nicht an die hose
man kann ja auch schnell geklaut werden
okay ich freue mich jetzt gerade wo
dieses leuchten abgeblieben ist ich hab
das glaube ich sogar in drei
verschiedenen farben bestellt und mir
wurde auch einmal angezeigt das ist
schon da ist ich hatte es auch meine ich
in den händen da muss ich noch mal
schauen nehme ich dann auf jeden fall in
den nächsten part wenn ihr sagt alex man
mache ich aber lasst bitte trotzdem
daumen nach oben da ansonsten waren dass
wieder einige verrückte ausgefallene
airports cases die man so im laden auf
jeden fall nicht kaufen kann
da habe ich auch noch gedacht ob ich
vielleicht mal hier in deutschland im
laden gehen und da cases kauf und die
dann so ein bisschen vergleiche weil die
im laden hier am steuer sind wenn ihr
bock drauf habt schreibt es gerne in die
kommentare
abonniert den kanal mein favourit ist
auf jeden fall der xbox controller dann
kommt die ikea tasche dann der spongebob
und dann die anderen sachen ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen heute haut rein check
meinen neuen kanal ab da kommen jeden
tag videos und 13.30 ist jetzt hier
wahrscheinlich grad eingeblendet
[Musik]